it really feels like they look at marvel
and they see what they're doing and
mostly just shoot for that rather than
shooting for why and how that stuff
actually works we don't need to try to
suddenly go back to we gotta make
everything heavily interconnected with
each other when that's what a lot of
this ends up reading to me like but then
also seems a little contradictory you're
saying you have stuff like todd
phillips's joker and you want to do more
of that
but what makes that movie good is it
doesn't feel like it needs to be
connected because it's his own thing
[Music]
what is up there reject nation greg and
john here today we are going to talk
about some warner brothers dc eu changes
the company that just can't seem to find
a direction to stick through
get there someday despite the fact that
they've been doing pretty alright lately
you know like the batman was a pretty
good hit the suicide squad while not a
big box office it supposedly did all
right on streaming it was really well
received by audiences and critics and
the peacemaker the peacemakers show i
was getting there just wait for me guys
leave a like if you can that would mean
a lot i don't know if you guys know
about this recently discovery and warner
brothers they made a deal it's now
called wb discovery i believe the deal
was made for one trillion dollars
they're just throwing money at this
thing
43 billion dollars i didn't really
follow the lead up to this merger
because the only thing i ever heard
about it was does this mean the snyder
burst will be restored is it finally
about to happen the starter best
restored kids they all say that david
zazlov loves that snyder variety put his
article yesterday morning from the time
that we're uploading this but i wanna do
a total overhaul on dc
entertainment honestly going through it
had me uh a bit worried about the future
okay so the whole article you can find
in the description box but we want to
focus on a few key points here so we
want to go within really fast and we're
going to talk about it afterwards so the
first thing is they want to have like a
kevin feige like leader i don't know if
you guys know this but warner brothers
has tried to have a kevin feige likely
for quite some time doesn't sound bad in
theory obviously and like i said none of
this actually sounds necessarily like a
terrible idea it's just going off of
track record past experiences
considering the fact that it seems like
anyone who tries to be the mcu they
generally fail at doing it here's what
the article says before the merger
closed zoslov head of discovery now
ahead of both vetted candidates with
experience in creating and nurturing
blockbuster intellectual property with
the goal of potentially finding someone
to serve as a creative and strategic
gaza
similar to what marvel has in kevin
feige one insider suggests that zasalov
was less interested in finding a
creative guru and more eager to hire
someone who had the type of business
background needed to keep all the
different factions of dc working more
harmoniously that actually makes a
little bit of sense if they want to find
a kevin feige like leader but the thing
that makes kevin feige so special not
just the fact that he's a businessman
but also because he really loves marvel
comics he really knows marvel and that's
why he has such a good connection with
the fans as well even when they make
changes in the movies generally speaking
you can tell this guy actually knows
what marvel's really all about and now
that i have all these different other
things going in dc i get that you would
need someone who could also be like i
need to know how to harmoniously bring
this all together you need somebody
who's invested in the breadth of
characters and the mythology but who
also has a good business sense i feel
like they really need to split the
difference
kevin feige likes story person who knows
the world but who also can keep things
running chop chop so they want to get dc
eu back to the point where everything
feels more connected basically you know
part of me is like part of making dc
special to me is the fact of how it
doesn't feel any more like it's so
reliant on that which has allowed for
other films that were really filmmaker
driven to really blossom but we'll dive
more into that in a second the article
goes on to say discovery insiders
believe that although dc has achieved
cinematic success with recent films such
as aquaman and the batman and lexa
coherent creative and brand strategy
yeah i kind of agree with that they seem
to shift their plans all the time here
depending on how each one does at the
box office they're very reactionary yeah
all the more reason to get somebody who
has a good business sense about these
things and discovery believes that
several top shelf characters such as
superman have been left to languish and
need to be revitalized i thought they
were revitalizing superman in terms of
whatever that jj abrams michael b jordan
one
see
it's not dead i mean i've heard reports
lately that they're still trying to
figure out the script and maybe having
some problems with that i feel like that
could easily change in a heartbeat if
they really find a track that they like
and they want more stuff like joker they
also believe that projects like top
phillips joker are a shining example of
how to build second characters from dc
library and should be exploited margot
robbie's harley quinn is another example
i'd be down for another birds of prey
absolutely despite the fact that it
causes a weird conversation on twitter
i'd be down for another birds of prey i
quite enjoyed that movie a lot and i
think harley quinn was also awesome in
the suicide squad absolutely so yeah i'd
be totally down for that weirdly going
online that was the one that seemed to
upset people a lot
was more more of a joke about like oh
come on guys have you not heard my
scarecrow stand-alone movie idea it
almost seems like they could flourish
just doing standalone movies and not
trying to be marvel whatsoever i'm not
against the idea of producers executive
producer studios having a say in what's
happening with the movies of course i'm
not against like that's fair they're
putting the money in it's just you know
a movie [ __ ] when you feel like this
whole movie is just studio notes a lot
of this reads to me like i think we'd be
going back to everything feeling like
shoehorn studio notes
i'm not saying that'll be the case it
just kind of communicates that way to me
right now whenever a studio even dc in
the past when they try to emulate more
of the marvel cinematic universe they
keep writing themselves into this weird
corner with their films seem like
they've become all about setting up to
get to some crossover movie some build
up that ultimately doesn't end up paying
off because their plan getting there was
not panning out and they've already
tried having leaders several times now
seems like what they've been doing
lately has been the best strategy so far
which is let them be more filmmaker
driven films that's why i think the
batman has such a great response like
i'm excited for the gotham shows that
matt reeves is working on he's making
like his own little bat burst and what i
think is really cool about what dcu has
on their hands is they're able to build
universes within universes really well
with james gunn doing the suicide squad
he's got his like suicide squad universe
happening with the peacemaker series and
both i thought were really great stuff
i'm already under the impression though
that especially with your flash movie do
you really need to do this you're
already setting up the multiverse so one
can just assume that they're connected
via the multiverse and that if it's not
worried about having crossovers or being
totally connected like we have to force
robert pattinson to now cross over into
one of these films just establish that
yeah it exists it's connected because
it's it's within the dc multiverse
itself what does this mean for current
films that they have in plan too because
i know that's also been put on halt but
i want the shazam trilogy to finish out
i want the aquaman trilogy to finish out
let's see what happens that ever heard i
want to see
everybody wants to see what happens with
aquaman three now
see what goes on there the absolute one
and i want them to do it yeah i mean it
almost seems like they have a perfect
opportunity to just sort of let
everything be where it is and yeah move
forward with a better plan but i don't
necessarily think there needs to be a
lot of retroactive restructuring i mean
yes you have a bit of a disparate
universe but from here on especially
with the multiverse i feel like it's not
really that famous last words difficult
to kind of see the lay of your land and
then streamline it moving forward and
take the best of what's worked so far
and perpetuate that i mean that's
essentially what marvel's been doing
just with a massive continuity and maybe
they'll find they don't need that
massive continuity so much as they need
just a universe that feels like it
houses all these characters or something
i'm sure with marvel there's constantly
conversations i'm sure behind the scenes
of we need to re-strategize this we need
to fix this we've seen them shift like
slots in their films before and films
have been canceled here or there so of
course they also will have the
discussion of re-strategizing it's a
constant part of game planning or
mapping something out this massive it's
just when you tell me stuff like they
want a kevin feige like leader like you
you've already you're not david we've
always wanted that and i feel like a lot
of time they don't really understand
what's made kevin feige so great at what
he's done with marvel what they're doing
right now seems to be doing just fine
because of the fact that they have the
multiverse at their disposal that
they've already established with crisis
on infinite ursa that are only gonna
solidify more with the flash movie we
don't need to try to suddenly go back to
we gotta make everything heavily
interconnected with each other when
that's what a lot of this ends up
reading to me like but then also seems a
little contradictory when you're saying
you have stuff like todd phillips's
joker and you want to do more of that
but what makes that movie good is it
doesn't feel like it needs to be
connected because it's his own thing so
much of the time hearing about wb and
and now discovery and all the things
they want to do with dc it really feels
like they look at marvel and they see
what they're doing and mostly just shoot
for that rather than shooting for why
and how that stuff actually works and i
feel like there is a sort of expectation
that these things will translate
immediately and i feel like you know of
course they want a new kevin feige and
for a more you know vertically
structured system but at the same time
that stuff takes time and a steady hand
to build and i think it's interesting
that they still prioritize at least as
of this account the business angle of
that because you need the heart and the
soul of that and i get that even marvel
is subject to the business side and you
know how the market speaks but they also
seem like
whenever they reshoot or whenever they
restructure they always make sure to
temper the characterizations and the
emotional cores and the spirit of those
stories and those characters in time
with that rather than fully going for
the market so i feel like the biggest
question to me now is what kind of a
business man is david zazla yeah at this
moment it sounds like the same plan
they've been shooting for for so long
but we'll see maybe they will restore
the snyder verse i'd like superman to
come back as well just as much as anyone
else alrighty well leave your thoughts
down below subscribe click that bell
what do you think about all this and
we'll talk to you guys soon